can I just skip to the end and say Oh
huge shock the over simplistic solution
isn't actually a solution okay everybody
so I really need to stop saying that I'm
done talking about certain things or or
I don't plan to do future videos on
certain things because I swear every
single time I do that something ends up
happening usually in my own comment
section that makes me goes crap I do
need to address that now don't I
bus is the case with the concept of
separating the artist from the art it
should not come to anybody surprise that
the reason that I feel the need to talk
about this is because of JK Rowling but
as with the last few times I brought
that up I really don't want to dwell on
her specifically but recognize that she
and the discourse and conversation
around her as the impetus for this so
when I did my video talking about where
Harry Potter is going to continue to fit
in my life and on this channel I saw a
lot of comments that were variations of
well we need to separate the artist from
the art and it wasn't so much the sheer
volume of them but the high percentage
of those comments that presented it like
oh well you just separate the artist
from the art this is why I always
separate the artists from they're
treating it like it's a cure-all like
it's a fix like he gets rid of the
problem I can't tell how serious people
are with how flippant you're using the
idea of separate the errors from the art
but you can't actually do that
the first thing is there were some
people in comments who seem to be taking
the reason that we need to separate the
artist from the art is because if we
don't then we are in a situation where
everything eventually gets canceled
we're not allowed to read anything or
taking any art by anyone because
everyone's human and everyone is flawed
and as those flaws get exposed we'll
never get to enjoy anything ever again
now that's a false binary you give me a
binary where either we completely ignore
the artist or we must get rid of
everything I'm gonna say no the binary
doesn't work big shock coming from me
breaking a binary hmm
that entire thing that's hyperbolic and
that's nonsense
only people with no concept of depth or
nuance whatsoever would claim that so
you need to banish that idea from your
head that if we don't separate from the
artists from the earth then we can't
enjoy anything ever and I will kind of
circle back on to the you're taking in
an enjoyment of these things in a little
bit but that's the first thing next up I
need to clarify something because a lot
of folks at the comments also seem to be
equating separating the arts from the
art which I don't think you can do with
death of the author which is something I
support very highly while these are two
concepts with a fair amount of overlap
philosophically they're not actually the
same thing
so what death of the author is it's the
idea that the originator of a piece of
art their interpretation of the art they
create is no more valid than anyone
elses and their interpretation of the
work does not supersede or invalidate
the interpretation of anyone who
partakes of that piece of art like as an
example if you were to read the lines of
which in the wardrobe the author of that
seus Lewis wrote it
very strongly as a Christian allegory
those themes are all over the book
they're very clear but if you read that
book and your interpretation of the work
is that it's not about faith or religion
but it's actually about broken family
units and Aslan is meant to represent
unity and putting in the work to be
together where's the white which
represents the fracturing of the family
dynamic and how that splintering can
poison things in forcings apart even
further death of the author says you are
allowed to have that interpretation of
the work and just because it isn't the
interpretation that the original author
that seus Lewis had doesn't mean you
don't get to have that you get to have
that cuz it's that as your experience
that's death of the author now what
definitely author doesn't do is it
doesn't address anything about who the
author is as a person it only deals with
interpretations of the work that that
author produces and this is why it's not
the same thing as separate the artist
from the art because pretty much anytime
anybody invokes the idea I've separate
the artist from the art what they are
advocating that you do is to not think
about the person behind the art it's not
about their interpretation of the orgasm
it's about ignoring who they are and
only looking at the art in and of itself
so wow that and death of the author are
philosophical cousins they're not
actually the same thing and that is why
I can be in favor of one and not the
other
so there's a couple of problems with
separating the artist from the art first
off it treats art like it exists in a
vacuum like it's something that was just
there it was always present and who
created it is irrelevant and that is a
very odd way to think about anything
because no piece of art just exists
Harry Potter was not a story that
existed out in the universe that
happened to be channeled through a
vessel named JK Rowling but could have
come from any other source because it
exists in a vacuum on its own now I'm
not claiming that anybody actually
believes that to be the case I know they
don't but to try and separate the artist
from the art is to treat art as if that
is the case as if it doesn't have a
source as if it doesn't have a meaning
as if it doesn't have influences and
background good features and bad that
are instilled in it from the person who
created it and to me first off that's a
very naive and kind of disrespectful way
to consume art any art whether it's art
you like or you don't and one of the
things that's really frustrating about
this for me is people tend to invoke it
when they want to take take part in a
piece of art that they enjoy created by
a person who they take issue with
especially in the back of my head what I
know you won't do that for a piece of
art you like created by a person who who
matches your moral values more closely
you're not going to separate that from
the artist but you will for this so it's
not about actually trying to enjoy the
piece of art unto itself the way some
people will claim that it is it's about
trying to placate your own conscience
and it's a cheat
an artist's beliefs whether they are as
evident in the text and as allegorical
as in something like the lines of which
in the wardrobe or if there is no
intentional projecting of the author's
beliefs in the narrative or the
characters regardless their beliefs
their worldviews their upbringing their
way of thinking and seeing the world is
why the story exists in the form that it
does the art does not exist absent the
artists now I know that this is a fact
that especially if you find out things
about an artist that you don't like as a
person makes things uncomfortable and I
understand that that is not pleasant and
that's not a nice thing to go through
but I honestly think it's something most
of us need to go through it's part of
being an adult like I'll give a pass to
kids reading Harry Potter I don't have
expectations of them to have grappled
with the issue of JK Rowling's
transphobic beliefs
I don't expect a nine-year-old to
grapple and have come to terms with that
I'm not even entirely sure I'd expect a
19 year old - I'd like to but I'm not
sure I can set it as an expectation but
a 29 year old 39 up up you don't get to
just duck out on being a mature consumer
of art because it makes you
uncomfortable and the sad reality is
that coming to terms with some of the
people who created pieces of art that
you like might mean you don't enjoy that
piece of art anymore it may in fact
taint it for you and that sucks
and look I stand by what I said before I
have not gotten rid of my Harry Potter
items I have not
reading Harry Potter to my daughter but
my own personal enjoyment of those
things is less so I know that it sucks
I've made the choice to hold on to these
things in the way that I'm choosing to
do so regardless of that because they do
still have value it is tarnished but
tarnishment does not make it worthless
again it's not a binary just because
it's not perfect doesn't mean we should
throw it away but you may also end up
coming to the decision that you need to
and that's fine that would be a mature
moral choice
so part of what frustrates me when I see
people make the argument for separate
the artists from the art is that when I
made my video about Harry Potter
that was not something that was done
spur the moment and my point in that was
not I'm never gonna think about who JK
Rowling is I had had internal debates
and conversations with friends and
people who mattered me trying to figure
out how I was going to move forward
I didn't toss it off as I will just
separate the areas from the art in order
to avoid having to do that because that
is immature and I would argue even
irresponsible to yourself and to the
appreciation of any piece of art
life is complicated and being an adult
means not ignoring and ducking out and
avoiding for your own comfort the
complications and that sucks being the
adult sucks I know that but you still
need to do it for yourself for your
growth for your appreciation of things
for your understanding of anything how
can you claim to appreciate a piece of
art if you are ignoring where it's
coming from and if by learning to come
to better understand where it comes from
if it makes it harder for you to enjoy
that then that is part of the
complicated reality of life and I'm
sorry but you don't get to just duck out
on that because it makes you
uncomfortable that having been said I
personally love the opinion that nobody
not me and not anybody else has any
business telling you how to process and
what conclusions to come to because if
you go through all of this if you come
to terms with the faults in the either
personhood or actions or beliefs of
someone who created a piece of art that
you love if you go through all that and
come out the other end still finding a
way that you're comfortable continuing
to enjoy that art I don't have a problem
with that so long as I know that if
somebody asks why do you still partake
of this art that you can answer it
that you can explain because it connects
to me in this way because it has this
high value and I understand the other
issues but this means so much to me
where I will get irritated with you is
if your answer is just I
think about it and that's what's saying
I separate the artist from the art is
it's going I'm not gonna think about it
and that I think people kind of do have
a right to get annoyed with you at not
to be rude nobody should be being rude
to anybody but to get annoyed with you
if when the question comes up how are
you still conscientiously partaking of
this piece of media
your answer is ah I just don't think
about it that's not okay you do need to
think about it and if you come to the
conclusion that you can still predict of
that media okay but do the work don't
put it off because it's hard because
you're disrespecting the work that you
claim to be enjoying because you are
failing to appreciate its origins
because that is part of appreciating you
a piece of art fully and if it truly
means that much to you why would you
ignore that it is disrespectful to the
people who are hurt by that artist if
their actions or their beliefs or their
statements have caused harm you are
saying to those people I don't I am
choosing to not think about that and
again if you this is not me saying you
can't partake of this art I said at the
beginning this is not a binary this is
not a this person's problematic you can
never enjoy their art again whether or
not you can join their art again that is
up to you and that's what I talked about
when I talked when I did my video on
problematic creators separating the
artists from the art is not a solution
it is a choice to avoid having to think
about things it sure as hell is not a
solution thank you very much for
watching please leave a comment like
subscribe whatever your thoughts are
just keep them civil down on the comment
section and until next time this council
is adjourned thank you very much for
watching I hope you enjoyed this video
you can help me out by going to patreon
and helping me keep this entire thing
going and of course I have merch and I
have other social media things for you
to check out as well but most
importantly just be sure that you be
safe be well and be kind
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]